good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy december 1st the
year is almost over and thank heaven it
is
2020 has been tough on everyone
americans are tired they're frustrated
divided and angry eight months of
non-stop crisis will do that to a
country everyone could use a break
unfortunately doesn't like we're getting
a break anytime soon because there's a
new
crisis on the horizon we learned about
it today it's a bad one we're sad to
tell you
this is a threat that imperils the very
existence of our nation no it's not a
mutated form of the coronavirus newly
arrived from asia
it's not an exotic new painkiller that
will silently kill yet another hundred
thousand americans in unfashionable
little towns
it's not even another exodus of
middle-class jobs to china it's worse
than any of that
the crisis is you and your sinfulness
your indelible personal bigotries
you are the threat to america that news
came today from the mayor of louisville
kentucky
that mayor's name is greg fisher as a
civic leader it's fair to say that greg
fischer has not been a success
louisville is a much worse place to live
than it was when he took over
so as a mayor greg fischer has failed
that's undeniable
so he's found a new calling now greg
fischer is a public health expert
that's a job with far fewer requirements
and a much more lenient grading scale
listen to dr fisher describe our new
pandemic
our systems are more than broken they
must be dismantled
and replaced that's why i'm announcing
today
i'm signing an executive order declaring
racism
a public health crisis in louisville
so racism is a public health crisis says
greg fischer
dr fisher plans to attack this crisis
with an executive order
will masks help contain the spread of
racism they certainly haven't before but
we'll see
or maybe we won't see the beauty of
fighting racism like fighting
sadness or alienation or existential
dread is that there aren't very good
measures
of progress you can't really know when
you've won
the battle goes on forever you're always
justified in fighting it of course by
definition
in the war against racism you are always
the good guy
no one can criticize your motives or
even your competence
compare that to normal politics much
easier
by conventional political standards greg
fisher is a disgrace
two of louisville's biggest employers
just left his city huge numbers of
people are still
dying from drug ods they had race riots
over the summer
louisville is a mess and it's fair to
say that greg fischer is at least partly
responsible for that mess
not surprisingly greg fischer has no
interest in talking about that
he'd much rather talk about your racism
so that's what he's doing
it's an old trick obviously al sharpton
doesn't pay his taxes then he calls you
a bigot for asking him about it
but the tactic suddenly seems more
popular than ever you see it everywhere
all of a sudden and there's a reason the
more obvious it becomes that the people
in charge
are stupid and selfish the more time
they spend attacking you and the country
they're supposed to be leading
they divide us to keep us from noticing
how awful they are
and unfortunately it works pretty well
and that's why they do it
let's say you were incompetent and you
didn't want anyone to know you were
what would you do well your first task
would be to destroy the meritocracy
that's a system that rewards people in
this country for their effort
and their talents as opposed to
rewarding them for irrelevant criteria
like
how they look a meritocracy is the main
threat to incompetent people
it keeps the incompetent from getting
rich and powerful and so they hate
it above all that's why they're tearing
it down
so what does it look like in practice to
tear down a meritocracy
well it looks a lot like joe biden
staffing a presidential administration
a recent piece in politico tells the
story according to politico's account
the congressional black caucus is
demanding that biden select a black
secretary of defense not a secretary of
defense who's good at defending
america a secretary of defense with the
correct skin color
now feminist groups are mad about this
says politico not mad because it would
leave the country
vulnerable no mad because they want a
female secretary of defense
why do they want a female secretary of
defense because they're females
the secretary of defense should look
like them because it's all about them
not about the pentagon or the country or
the military threats we might face in
the future it is about identity
which is to say it's about narcissism
when i see people in power i must see
myself
that's the demand and not just the
demand at the pentagon
here's how vox.com covered the race to
replace steve mnuchin at the treasury
department
quote lal brainerd who is white is seen
on wall street and by her skeptics on
the left
as the most likely treasury secretary
raphael bostic who would be the first
black and first openly gay treasury
secretary is also receiving some
consideration
fox went on to note that some quote
hispanic democrats are upset that there
are quote no hispanic candidates
legitimately in the mix for the other
three top jobs
in the bid administration got that
hispanic black
gay those are categories they're not
people they're not individuals
this is about identity not country it's
about balkanization
not unity straight white men are the
enemy
says the party led by one and so it goes
it's hard to imagine anything uglier
than this
it's hard to imagine a more abrupt
cul-de-sac this doesn't go anywhere that
you'd want to go
it ends with discord and worse but it
continues
listen to the huffington post's account
of the struggle to fill kamala harris's
senate seat in the state of california
three main camps and their subgroups are
trying to influence california governor
newsom
those advocating for a black woman those
advocating for a latino
and those advocating for a member of the
lgbt community
end quote in other words certain jobs
for certain identities certain skin
colors have
pre-prescribed roles how is that
different from a traditional caste
system
how is that better than the jim crow
south those are fair questions
but no one ever asked them instead the
media just applaud
i don't remember a cabinet or a senior
appointments
that are this diverse i suspect he may
well have one of the most diverse
cabinets in the history of this country
the most diverse staff
that a transition has ever had he
promised the most diverse cabinet
uh in history the most diverse ever
assembled
and it could be the most diverse ever
assembling what is essentially
the most diverse cabinet in history
president-elect biden vice
president-elect kamala harris
have the most diverse and competent team
a president and a vice president could
possibly have
so obviously those people are
unimpressive despite their credentials
mindlessly repeating the latest
corporate slogans
but listen to what they're saying
diversity that is the overriding goal
of every appointment notice what they
don't say no one ever explains what
exactly diversity is not with any
precision or justifies that definition
no one dares to
and yet diversity is now required
by corporate america their definition of
diversity the nasdaq for example
has proposed new listing rules that
require companies to quote
have or explain what they do not have at
least two diverse
directors including one who
self-identifies as female
and one who self-identifies is either an
underrepresented minority
or lgbtq plus end quote not to be
outdone the bank credit suisse announced
it it has created an
index of 350 quote lgbtq
inclusive companies and they will of
course be rewarded accordingly
now think this through for a minute
there's a lot of money
at stake here with these definitions and
a lot of power that attaches
at some point we're going to need highly
specific ways to verify
that the people who are benefiting from
these categories deserve to
that they're indeed women whatever that
now means or that they are legitimately
lgbtq plus so all that verification look
like
blood tests home monitoring we'll find
out at some point unfortunately
jenny allen doesn't seem worried about
that yellen is joe biden's pick for
treasury secretary and she's on board
with all of it
mindlessly she's rich enough to be the
ellen just explained that eliminating
social disparities
hard to define is a central goal
of federal economic policy going forward
watch
we risk missing the obligation to
address deeper structural
problems inequality stagnant wages
racial disparities in pay job
opportunities housing
food security and small business lending
that deny wealth building to communities
of color
gender disparities that keep women out
of the workforce
and keep our economy from running at
full force
it's a convergence of tragedies
yeah so the idea is everybody pays money
into the federal treasury that puts you
in jail if you don't it's
compulsory they'll use force if they
need to but only some people benefit
depending upon who janet yellen thinks
should benefit so there's that
we should debate that it's worth
debating but step back a few feet what's
more
interesting is that everything you just
heard is the opposite of the actual
truth and if you're actually in favor of
diversity
real diversity you notice that the
diversity measures they're proposing
won't make anything more diverse just
the opposite
these proposals are merely a way for the
people in charge to hire more of their
friends
what you're seeing is an attempt to
preserve and codify
the class system that is already in
place and unfortunately
that is growing more rigid by the day if
you really wanted to flatten america's
social structure
and we want that and you should too
because again class systems are bad
and we now have one if you wanted a
flatter society
you would demand a return to meritocracy
you'd want a system where
anyone no matter where they were born or
what they look like or who they slept
with
could succeed that's what we used to
have it's why we were proud of america
but it's the opposite of what the left
is now demanding
so if you really wanted to make
companies more diverse and again we are
for that
you would try to actually diversify them
that means you would hire people who
were not in any sense
like you people with different
backgrounds
actually different backgrounds you'd
hire more people with technical degrees
for example and fewer who'd studied
marketing or communications
you'd find people who lived in rural zip
codes deep in rural zip codes
you'd seek out employees who were deeply
involved in their churches or owned
guns or who had close family members who
died of opioid ods
and more than anything on day one you
would put a cap
on the number of employees who went to
elite colleges let's just start with the
top 100 on the u.s news annual list you
would outright ban a harvard yale
princeton and stanford graduates
completely
they've got enough representation to
last for the next half century
you'd make any previous employment at
mckinsey and company or any other absurd
consulting firm
instantly disqualifying you would look
beyond race and sex to the cultural
markers that actually matter and that
actually determine later success in a
class system
you would subtract points from any
applicant who'd ever spent the night on
nantucket or martha's vineyard or st
bart's and you would add points to
applicants who vacation in branson or
lake mead or the florida panhandle
you will start an aggressive affirmative
action program for fat
people for deer hunters for anyone who
drives an american car
or eats dinner while wearing a hat are
those people represented on corporate
boards
i don't think so find a fat person in
corporate america there's not one
why is that you know why
our leaders are doing precisely the
opposite of any of that
and it tells you everything what you're
seeing is the ruling class pulling up
the ladder as they always do as all
ruling classes do
how many of the people lecturing you
about diversity come from exactly the
same
elite background well pretty much all of
them so what they're advocating for is
people just like themselves
we can give you a thousand examples
we'll just pick one take marcus mabry
he runs global digital programming at
cnn been on journalism forever
he's now one of cnn's most energetic
diversity enforcers
maybe he never ends a sentence without
using the word diverse that's his job
and yet here's the interesting part he
himself went to high school at
lawrenceville academy
he got two degrees from stanford then he
spent decades at newsweek the new york
times and
twitter so naturally he claims to be
highly concerned about inclusion
listen to him from just a few years ago
lecturing his then employer about it
there is a lot of work to do at twitter
and throughout tech
and is one of the reasons i came to
twitter which i think it's so important
that we're at the table
um it was true at the new york times too
but we have to make more of us we have
to create more of us
and not just african-american but also
uh latino and hispanics who are very
much also underrepresented in technology
and at twitter
uh and twitter's com i'm convinced our
current leadership is committed
to improving that diversity but there's
a lot of work to do
there's a lot of work to do to make sure
that more of us are at the table people
went to lawrenceville and got a master's
degree at stanford they're not enough
we're underrepresented marcus mabry now
on the board of one of the most
expensive boarding schools in the world
is fighting the man of course he is
it's working for him it's working for
all his friends it's just not working
for you and it's not intended
to you're excluded from their inclusion
but you knew that